time for drew's news the only news that
kindly requests eight feet of your
city's finest sandwich
and here to help me chop this bad boy is
my trusty co-pilot rusty rasmus hi hi
everybody
i have to say i'm a little distracted by
this humongous philly cheesecake by the
way gino i swear i'm gonna motorboat
this silly cheesesteak like nobody's
business
i'm so excited first of all we're riding
the desk from east to west all season
long and today we're thrilled to be here
in the city of brotherly love
yes please we're also here at the iconic
love sculpture by artist robert indiana
a leader in the pop art movement he
first designed this as a painting in
1964 and brought the sculpture here in
1976 but it's so much more than a
sculpture it was his life's work and
robert indiana did thousands of love
paintings and felt everybody should have
love he said he considered the word to
be a one sentence poem i love this spot
for the news desk ross now this is a
four letter word i can get behind yes
doesn't the world need just a little
more love always
so much
[Applause]
well another four-letter word i can also
get behind is meat a huge thank you to
you local legends at gino state
there they are right now
live and in the flesh
they have been serving authentic philly
cheese sticks since 1966.
ross what's in a philly cheesesteak hit
me everything you ever want in life is
inside a philly cheesesteak you have
thinly sliced rib eye perfectly fried
onions and your choice of cheese
american provolone or
whiz now what are you are you which
cheese would you choose actually i'd
like to ask gino what is in your philly
cheesesteak because that's the one i
trust
well drew there's three types of cheeses
we got american provolone and whiz we
had to make you the famous one the wiz
right in front of you enjoy
now
i think when in philly you kind of just
go big right
drew look how petite your size it look
at that peace drew
okay
oh my god
okay
this is perfection
oh my god um
this is incredible incredible
okay i'm going to keep picking in
relationships you keep eating i want to
talk about this
should you put your your relationship
your partner up on a pedestal well metro
reports that pedestaling is a new that's
hard to say pedestaling is a new term
for an old habit over idealizing the
person you're dating or who you want to
date so for example if you say things
like oh she's just too good for me or
he's out of my league and if you think
if i could just be with that person my
life would be perfect well that is
called pedestaling and if you ask me it
is a red flag therapists say the root of
this habit is your own insecurity and
when they say when you pedestal people
you tend to do it again and again and
again have you ever done it
you know
i definitely have done that you have
absolutely let me put relationships in
terms of football anybody here love the
philadelphia eagles
okay so let's let me do a football
metaphor for relationships i think
everyone in a relationship should meet
each other at the 50-yard line you've
got to be equal people in this or it's
never going to work so if you're with
someone who you think is completely out
of your league then you've got some
inner work to do on you
that's what i think i agree all right
you can't come to philly and not think
of hometown hero rocky jogging up those
iconic stairs right there
right there in those iconic sweats yes
by the way i also love when he does like
the meat locker of course well deadline
reports that the man behind the champ
sylvester stallone has hit a new
hollywood milestone
sly stars in the suicide squad which hit
number one at the box office which means
stallone has now had a number one movie
in six consecutive decades wow
that's why he's the champ he's made 46
films with 20 number ones like rocky
rambo cliffhanger driven and the
expendables congrats to sly on an
amazing career that just keeps going
absolutely i always love sylvester
stallone because my growing up my dad
always called me rocky really yeah i
don't know why maybe i reminded him of
sylvester stallone in a way you know
what i'll put him on a pedestal any day
i'll take that
[Music]